[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire dans l' affaire dite du
siècle qui avait vu quatre associations
écologistes poursuivre l'état en justice
pour son inaction en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
le tribunal administratif de paris vient
de rendre son verdict l'état a bien
commis une faute en ne tenant pas ses
engagements de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre sur la période 2015 2018 et il
a été condamné à verser un euro
symbolique aux quatre associations
requérantes
mais la question de savoir si la france
est à la hauteur ou pas des enjeux
climatiques ne se pose pas seulement au
tribunal il y a également le projet de
loi climat et résilience qui a été
présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres un texte élaboré à partir des
propositions des 150 citoyens de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat et
qui est censé réduire de 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 par rapport à ce qu'ils étaient en
1990 un texte jugé insuffisant pour les
uns trop contraignant pour les autres
alors la france en fait l ac ou en fait
elle trop et surtout fait-elle ce qu'il
faut et pas le contraire de ce qu'il
faudrait faire
vaste débat que nous allons tenter
d'avoir avec nos deux invités
le premier c'est rémy prud'homme et que
de myst professeur émérite à
l'université paris xii vous avez été
directeur adjoint de la direction de
l'environnement l ocde il consultant
fréquent de la banque mondiale vous êtes
l'auteur de l'idéologie du réchauffement
et du mythe des énergies renouvelables
votre nouveau livre s'intitule sans
caillou dans la chaussure de monsieur
macron il est paru lui aussi aux
éditions de l'artilleur ce sont vos
analyses sous forme de court essai de
quelques pages sur l'actualité des trois
dernières années pour vous rémy
prud'homme est ce que la france est à la
hauteur des enjeux climatiques
ah je dirais oui je dirais même que l
est au-dessus
ces enjeux climatiques et que elle elle
envisage d'en faire plus qu'il serait
raisonnable
donc pour vous elle en fait trop
dominique bourg vous êtes philosophe
professeur honoraire à l'université de
lausanne vous avez présidé jeu
qu'en décembre 2018 le conseil
scientifique de la fondation nicolas
hulot êtes l'auteur entre autres
d'écologie intégral coécrit avec
christian aspergé et de la marche contre
l'humanité le dernier ces retours sur
terre 35 propositions
ils sont tous les trois parus ces livres
aux presses universitaires de france
même question est ce que la france ait
été à la hauteur des enjeux climatiques
ont fait l ac ou en fait elle trop suivi
la réponse n'est pas une question
d'opinion
la réponse à une question science pour
le coup et là effectivement une question
de droit on vient les voir mais les deux
chansons différents donc là le haut
conseil sur le climat vient se prononcer
lui la sûr que non elle n'en fait pas
assez et alors cette même un cocasse qui
nous arrive puisque là le gouvernement
vient d'être condamné à la suite de la
plainte
la sphère du siècle mais je vous
rappelle que cette plainte la halle
s'inscrit en continuité avec celle de
damien carême conduite par corinne
lepage et le conseil d'état leur avait
donné raison et là effectivement la
france envers vide en détail n'est pas
la hauteur de ces enjeux
si un engagement les les fameux trois
fois 20 ans mais les évidemment encore
moins par rapport à la réalité et à ce
qu'on en cours avec les enjeux
climatiques c'est à mon avis plus
important encore mais il est drôle si
vous voulez que à peine après l'homme la
décision du juge administratif
le gouvernement recommande c'est à dire
que prendre des engagements qui sont
venus à moitié chemin de ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire par rapport à ses
anciens engagements sur les trois fois
20 ans quand on parlera tout à l'heure
vous êtes d'accord
rémy prud'homme non pas du tout là la
sphère du tribunal administratif est
très simple l'état a pris des
engagements qui étaient intenables
il ne les a pas tenues qui donc un
certain nombre d'entités très politique
en vérité l'accusent de ne pas avoir
tenu ses engagements
les juges ne peuvent que dire oui c'est
vrai l'état n'a pas tenu ses engagements
sauf que si maintenant on se met à
poursuivre les gouvernements lorsqu'ils
ne tiennent pas les promesses qu'ils ont
formulées les tribunaux vaut quand même
être très encombré oui deux villes
bourgs enfin c'est carrément un gain est
ce que j'entends en fait il est vrai le
les trois fois 20 européen c'était trois
engagements différence était
effectivement aller jusqu'à 20%
d'énergie de nerfs d'énergies
renouvelables ça c'était un engagement
contraignant le gouvernement n'y est pas
arrivé c'est un engagement sur les
émissions alors qu'il eût été très
faible puisque à l'époque c'était un
engagement aussi avec pas en place la
france avait un engagement quasi nulle
de réduction du fait du côté très peu
carbonée de sa production d'électricité
alors que l'allemagne et à l'époque
c'était moins 35%
donc là effectivement cet engagement là
franchement il était très facile de le
tenir et sur la question d'efficacité
énergétique c'était un engagement non
contraignant pour que jude administratif
cdc se ne s'est pas prononcé sur le
sujet alors en fait non les aux nerfs on
était très mauvais les allemands et bien
d'autres sont bien meilleurs sur le
sujet dire que c'était un engagement à
quitter trop fort et qu'il était
impossible de le tenir je ne comprends
pas bien pour moi ça c'est une galéjade
alors expliquez vous rêvez prud'hommes
parce que nous savons que pour vous les
objectifs fixés étaient d'été pas
réaliste d'un e
il va dire que les allemands font mieux
que nous en matière d'énergies
renouvelables
c'est assez ridicule le prix de
l'électricité en allemagne est
exactement le double de ce qu'il est en
france
alors si vous trouvez que c'est ce qu'il
faut faire doubler le prix de
l'électricité en france avec tout ce que
ça veut dire pour les gens qui n'ont pas
l'argent pour se chauffer l'hiver alors
là vous avez raison mais il y a beaucoup
de gens en particulier les gens les plus
pauvres qui pensent que
à voir les énergies renouvelables
allemande
ça va contribuer à doubler le prix de
l'électricité et que ça n'est pas une
bonne chose
le melbourne non mais c'est pas le même
problème si vous voulez vous voulez me
dire ils ne les ont pas tenus et cèdera
ils n'ont pas développé des
renouvelables au bon niveau mais pas me
dire en même temps parce qu'ils ont
développées et qu'ils ont bien atteint
leurs objectifs leur énergie leur
électricité est trop cher c'est l'un ou
l'autre mon cher monsieur c'est pas les
deux à la fois mais surtout
effectivement là vous avez en revanche
raison c'est que dans tous ces enjeux
climatiques et puis encore une fois
c'est même assez ridicule si vous êtes
isolé climat du reste le climat je le
rappelle c'est simplement deux
paramètres c'est notamment enfin
essentiellement la chaleur et l'humidité
c'est les deux paramètres qui font que
la vie est viable sur terre donc on veut
toucher au climat vous touchez à la
viabilité de la planète il suffit
simplement de rappeler ça sinon on
n'était pas du tout dans les choses
sérieuses alors oui il peut y avoir un
problème il peut y avoir un problème de
justice sociale d'accès l'énergie je
vous rappelle qu'en france et là vous
avez totalement raison
il y a au nom 1,6 million précaires
énergétiques c'est à dire de gens qui
dépensent au moins 10% de leurs revenus
pour se chauffer pour produire l'eau
chaude et jeunes intégra même pas la
cible et les dépenses qui leur sont
nécessaires pour se rendre au travail
avec une voiture donc de deux façons
carbonée donc là on a vraiment un
problème effectivement il faut bien
pouvoir concilier les deux c'est à dire
à la fois la réduction de nos émissions
et puis effectivement le faire de telle
sorte que ce soit acceptable pour pour
les ménages surtout les ménages qui ont
ciblé les plus faibles revenus je
rappelle qu'à l'échelle mondiale c'est
les 10% les plus riches de la possible
de la population mondiale qui aimait
grosso modo c'est un peu arrondie qui
est maître 50 % des gaz à effet de serre
mondiaux et puis c'est les 50 % les plus
pauvres qui n'en maîtres queux disent
donc effectivement il faut bien résonner
dans le cadre d'une écologie sociale de
façon c'est très traditionnelle des
inégalités entre les gens
pour lui pour fondement des inégalités
en matière d'accès aux ressources
naturelles
donc effectivement inégalités sociales
et inégalités écologiques de ce côté là
se recouvrent bon et ça c'est vraiment
un défi important c'est évidemment un 2
2 2 des gares bonne et notre énergie
sans augmenter les inégalités c'est un
vrai défi ce n'est pas une chose simple
à san mamés prud'hommes ah ben je suis
content que monsieur moore soit d'accord
avec moi sur ce point tout à fait
essentiel n'est y en a un autre sur
lequel on peut se dire quelque chose
c'est que réduire les rejets de co2 de
l'ensemble de la planète
premièrement on n'est pas certain que ce
soit absolument indispensable on est
encore moins certain qu'ils aient la
moindre urgence dans cette affaire la
température - où la moyenne des
températures du globe s'est élevé d'à
peu près 1 degrés au cours des 150
dernières années ce qui fait que quand
on nous parle d'urgence jeunes ont
l'impression que quelque chose de très
sérieux
alors moi je vous réponds sur ce point
là c'est très précis je vais m'appuyer
si vous voulez sur la dernière
évaluation c'est celle du maître le met
donc le service météo anglais tous les
ans nous faire un calcul fondé sur les
quatre labo au monde qui sont
spécialisés dans l'établissement de la
température mondiale
en fait par rapport à une moyenne si
vous voulez la seconde moitié du 19e
siècle c'est-à-dire 850 1900 et bien
nous sommes par rapport à la moyenne ces
tranches de cette période
nous sommes à un degré de dixièmes de
plus et contrairement à ce qui vient
d'être dit en fait on a pris deux
dixièmes entre la le début du 20e siècle
et les années 40
1940 en fait là on était dans la queue
de comète de la sortie du petit âge
glaciaire qui a annulé à allécher de la
planète commence très lentement au tout
début du xiiie siècle et qui dans la
partie ouest de l'europe
pas ses crimes concernés à l'époque en
tout cas nous ascendant est bien là est
devenu très violents à partir de 13 135
336 à peu près et sans ça vous comprenez
pas la peste noire qui a emporté la
moitié de l'humanité et notamment la
moitié des européens
donc là on était dans la queue de comète
en fait après vous avez un plateau et
puis vous avez la température qui
commence à monter ils ont vers la dans
le milieu vers la fin des années 70 est
en fait le la température augmente et
d'un degré en 40 ans un 1/2 en 40 ans
est gigantesque
si vous regardez ce qui se passe dans ce
qu'on appelle le quaternaire ça fait 2
millions 600 mille ans que ça dure c'est
à dire ce que ça veut dire ça fait 2
millions 600 mille ans que verrait la
glace aux pôles un pôle nord au pôle sud
on a connu les alternances de glacières
long en gros 80 minant d'inter glaciaire
du couvain milan est en fait quand on
passe de l'un à l'autre la température
augmente d'un degré sauf accident il ya
des accidents sur l armée d'un degré
tous les mille ans là je rappelle qu'on
a un degré en 40 ans et il est probable
qu'on soit proche est bien proche d'un
degré dans les 20 ans qui viennent c'est
à dire qu'en fait on atteindra les 2
degrés entre 2040 et 2060 mais avec le
recul qu'on a si vous voulez sur nos
modèles si fort général et scénarios les
plus les plus pessimistes qui se réalise
toujours
donc il est très fier vraiment fortement
possible qu'on soit à 2 degrés dès le
début il a décidé 2040
j'ai peut-être pas le temps de
développer mais mes deux alors déjà
aujourd'hui c'est pas simple on le voit
mais s'assure que deux degrés sous les
effets ne sont pas linéaires les effets
augmente donc oui il ya une urgence
absolue et d'où le fait que s'ils
voulaient à peu près partout pour se
donner des objectifs alors l'europe
c'est pour ça que la la la la la loi que
soumet le gouvernement aujourd'hui enfin
que va se mettre le gouvernement au
parlement
c'est un peu un gag parce que l'union
européenne elle même elle est à moins 55
% de baisse des émissions
moi j'habite à lausanne dans l'état d'un
côté à genève 10 ans soit moins 60% là
après on viendra comme en détailler
comment simuler on calcule ces choses là
c'est en gros
ce qu'il faudrait faire dans les dix ans
qui viennent mais à une échelle mondiale
pas évidemment seulement la france
seulement l'europe seulement les usa
pour éviter d'exploser les deux degrés
le fait qu'on va les atteindre c'est
quasi certain aujourd'hui il faut bien
comprendre si vous voulez c'est que
quand vous émettez des gaz à effet de
serre eh bien ils vont nous produire
leurs effets de réchauffement c'est un
des effets réchauffement mais il est
fondamental pas dit s'ils ont assez
rapidement c'est un tiers de cet effet
est en fait les deux autres tiers
ils vont se déployer sur des décennies
ce qui fait que grosso modo on peut dire
que la température dont on va souffrir
dans une vingtaine d'années
et bien c'est grosso modo quasi
totalement nos les émissions accumulé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc quand bien même on deviendrait
vertueux à partir de maintenant c'est ça
changerait pas grand chose à ce qui va
nous arriver
en gros a compté 2040 et alors il faut
bien faire attention
vous avez deux choses dans cette affaire
et en termes de politiques publiques il
ya deux choses très différentes à
conduire
la première chose à conduire c'est
effectivement participer à l'effort de
réduction mondiale des émissions ça vous
fait si les autres ne le font pas ou si
les autres le font mieux que vous pas de
toute façon vous en et bénéficierez pas
forcément plus d'autant que les effets
vont être très différent géographique
mais en revanche l'autre partie de
l'action et qui n'a de sens que si on
fait la première dire que si on réduit
les émissions
c'est tout ce qu'on appelle adaptation
je vous rappelle que vous avez eu à
paris en juillet 2019
vous avez eu un un summum un pic de
température de 42,6 en juillet 2019
c'est un juin 2019 je crois et en pendu
par ryanair c'est marrant parce qu on
aurait pu s'attendre à linverse vous
avez jusqu'à 43 degrés fin juin de la
même année 2019
vous avez vu dans un petit village de
l'hérault une pointe à 46 degrés ce qui
fait que si vous voulez dans la décennie
qui vient elle est dessinée qui vont
suivre
les piles de température au delà de 40
dans nos villes vont devenir de plus en
plus fréquents une ville comme paris à
40 degrés c'est tout simplement
insupportable raconte une anecdote c on
était pourtant là on était en mai 2003
2003 faisant soutenez c'est la fameuse
canicule d'août
mais en mai il ya des jeux un pic de
chaleur je recevais un collègue un
chercheur indien qui habite bangalore
c'est quand même pas dans l'arctique et
il venait passer trois jours à paris
évidemment paris c'est une ville très
minéral il m'a dit je ne reviendrai plus
jamais dans cette ville tellement
c'était insupportable je dois vous dire
que ce jour là j'en ai appris la colombe
râle parce que m'entendre dire par un
intérêt que paris et deauville
insupportable de chaleur c'était assez
étonnant donc voilà si on ne sait si on
ne fait pas ce travail d'adaptation et
ce travail d'adaptation notamment cccc
revégétaliser ça si vous voulez pas fait
des décennies avant ses cendres en
l'efficacité tout simplement nous ville
vont devenir insupportable
évidemment bien d'autres bien d'autres
aspects et s'assure mal tant pour à les
aborder
donc oui par rapport à ces enjeux la
saison jus qu'on connaît et si vous
voulez en termes de modélisation
climatique on arrête les galéjades je
vous rappelle que les premiers modèles
de climat du climat mondial ont été mis
au point dans la décennie 60 quand
reportez vous au sommet sur l'homme et
l'environnement de stockholm en juin 72
souvenez vous c'était le rapport ward du
bo vous aviez déjà admis chapitre à
l'époque 72 je répète qui était
consacrée au changement climatique
en fait le consensus sur le
réchauffement il s'est fait à la
conférence de villars en 85 et très
rapidement d'ailleurs très rapidement
trois ans après vous avez la création du
giec en 80 minutes elles puissent ici si
vous voulez et en fait on dispose si
vous voulez maintenant de beaucoup de
plusieurs familles de modèles il ya une
cinquantaine de modèles qui travaille au
monde et quand on vous dessine des
scénarios c'est on prend la convergence
de ces différents modèles et n'ouvrent
la latitude lorsque les modèles
divergent
donc en fait ce qui est intéressant sur
ces questions là ce n'était pas une
question d'opinion je m'en fous
complètement j'oublie tout de suite ça
ne m'intéresse pas c'est une question de
science
alors c'est sûr c'est pas la science
d'homologie du 19e siècle à on est sur
une science interprétative
mais on a le recul de 10 ont 50 ans de
modélisation derrière nous entassons
laisser conter je vous interromps pardon
mais on va pas faire un débat sur ni sur
les conséquences du réchauffement si sur
les projections climatiques pour ceux
que ça intéresse le le drass vient
d'être publié d'ailleurs par le par
météo france on peut y voir toutes les
projections au delà de 2050
département par département propose de
revenir à la politique de la france plus
particulièrement vous parliez des
énergies renouvelables rémy prud'homme
en fait on trop pour favoriser les
énergies renouvelables le solaire
l'éolien qui vous semblent pas
particulièrement efficace dans la lutte
contre les les pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre oui
mais prudent vous entendez le oui oui je
vous d'entente
s'agissant des énergies renouvelables
savez vous quelle est à l'heure à
laquelle nous parlons la production
d'électricité solaire en france
en réfléchissant un peu vous allez
trouver la réponse exacte elle est de
zéro kilowatts et pour cause il fait
nuit le water si on considère une heure
parce qu'il n'ya pas de soleil alors
l'idée que l'on peut jouer avec ça
enlever des centrales de fessenheim
qu'il projetait pas du tout de co2 et
mettre à la place des centrales solaires
qui vont produire de l'électricité fait
semblant d'oublier cette évidence que
ça ne sont pas les mêmes kilowattheure
les kilos le problème des renouvelables
c'est qu'on ne sait pas quand elles vont
bien vouloir produire de l'électricité
on le sait un peu pour le solaire on
sait qu'il n'en produira jamais les
soirs d'hiver qui se trouvait
précisément le moment où on a besoin de
s'éclairer ou de se chauffer mais on ne
le sait pas exactement
s'agissant de l'éolien on ne sait pas si
au moment où on en a le plus besoin
il y aura bien du vent ou si au
contraire il n'y en aura pas du tout
donc l'idée que l'on peut remplacer des
de l'électricité au gaz hydraulique
nucléaire par de l'électricité éolienne
et photovoltaïque est une plaisanterie
et vous pouvez multiplier le nombre
d'éoliennes à l'heure qu'il est vous
n'aurez pas un kilowatt heure de plus
pourquoi parce que l'électricité ne se
stocke pas à la différence de beaucoup
d'autres actes la plupart même des
autres activités industrielles alors
tant qu'on n'aura pas inventé un procédé
de stockage à grande échelle un coût
raisonnable ce qui arrivera peut-être
d'ailleurs parce que il ya des
chercheurs qui s'y emploie ici emploi
vrai dire depuis volta depuis ça fait
deux siècles qui s'y emploient ils n'ont
pas encore trouvé me trouveront
peut-être ce jour là on pourra se poser
la question des renouvelables
intermittentes
un autre point que l'on peut souligner à
propos des intermittents c'est que on a
l'habitude d'ajouter deux choses qui
n'ont rigoureusement rien à voir qu'ils
sont l'électricité hydraulique qui l a à
tous les avantages qui effectivement
renouvelables et que l'on peut
trollé parce que on peut ouvrir les
barrages quand on en a besoin et et
produire de l'électricité
d'un côté et on ajoute ça à
l'électricité éolienne et photovoltaïque
qui elle est intermittente et surtout
qui est aléatoire
donc là il ya un truc qui permet de
faire apparaître des gros pourcentages
mais qui est quelque chose de
complètement déraisonnables la raison
étant que malheureusement on ne peut
plus augmenter la production
d'électricité hydraulique
on a déjà à utiliser à peu près tous les
endroits notre pays comme la france
c'est pas vrai dans un pays comme l'inde
ou comme beaucoup de pays d'afrique
mais dans un pays européen on ne peut
pas augmenter l'électricité hydraulique
et d'ailleurs quand on en parle en se
camouflant côté cache sexe dans
l'électricité hydraulique qui permet de
faire avaler la pilule du non
renouvelable donc la question de savoir
si on en a assez et est une question qui
ne ce n'est pas une affaire de de
quantité d'électricité vous pouvez
encore une fois c'est une affaire
d'ajuster le la production d'électricité
à la demande d'électricité qui varie
beaucoup dans le temps d'une heure à
l'autre d'un mois à l'autre d'une
semaine à l'autre
dominique bourg est ce que c'est
raisonnable de vouloir réduire le nombre
des centrales nucléaires pour les
remplacer par les énergies renouvelables
alors que le nucléaire c'est bien plus
efficace
c'est bien moins cher et épicée c'est
bien plus décarbonés aussi que les le
l'éolien par exemple si vous permettez
je viens par rapport à cette question
mais je leur ai un peu plus globale pour
que le on a deux minutes après fait une
pause mais allez-y pendant deux minutes
voilà alors je vais jouer de travil mais
là ce que je virais par tonale avec ce
que vient de tenir
monsieur prudhomme si vous voulez nous
autres êtres humains on sait pas
produire de l'énergie a annoncé la
capter on sait la transportait l'a
transformé ça vous a pas échappé chacune
de ces opérations exige de l'énergie
donc on a un ratio on a un ratio entre
l'énergie qu'on emploie et puis
finalement celle qu'on récupère
effectivement quand on regarde si vous
voulez les renouvelables août le
problème kkr a souligné monsieur
prudhomme qui est tout à fait juste
inquiets celui la disponibilité et celui
du stockage
vous avez aussi celui du ratio est en
fait aujourd'hui si vous regardez en
tout cas jusqu'en 2018
là ce qu'on a su faire à l'échelle
mondiale on n'a pas su produire virait
un seul gramme décarbonés en fait on a
su ajouter des énergies on les a empilé
et est en fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on
produisait de moins carboné avec les
renouvelables étaient en manger par deux
par deux choses d'une part le fait que
pour les produits on a besoin d'énergies
carbonées la pelote pétrole notamment
d'une part et d'autre part par
l'augmentation de la consommation
donc si vous regardez les différentes
courbes vous regarde et que vous n'y a
aucune baisse des émissions en fait il
voulait la continuité de la hausse des
émissions à manger le peu qu'on pouvait
peut-être dégagé avec les renouvelables
c'est peut-être pas vrai pour 2019 y
avait un petit tassement qui était sans
doute due au développement des nerfs
dans le monde et on pourrait imaginer
retenu la crise que vit la plus
compliquée mais on peut imaginer que que
ça se produise donc en fait si vous
imaginez que vous aurez la même quantité
d'énergie disponible dans une société
décarbonés que dans une société
carbonées et que vous ferez autant voler
les avions et cetera que vous aurez
autant de voitures qui circulent çà je
crois que c'est un leurre et que c'est
pas possible c'est à dire que le
changement de deux sources énergétiques
c'est forcément un changement
relativement profond de société mais sur
sur des décennies maintenant juste
encore un mot si j'ai trente secondes
sur le sur le nucléaire
mais je vous les donne juste je vous les
donne juste après la pause qui prévient
[Musique]
avec le climat ou encore la crise
sanitaire la crise économique est l'un
des principaux défis qui attendent joe
biden nous avons plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui perçoivent des indemnités
de chômage maintenant le plan de
monsieur byden ne remet pas les gens au
travail ici proba soit vous avez
extinction de la croissance totalement
ou alors vous laisser filer la monnaie
et tout d'un coup vous allez vous
retrouver comme au venezuela ou ailleurs
nous avons besoin d'une reconstruction
économique massive et ni monsieur trump
oui monsieur byden semble capable ou
désireux de le faire d'où là c'est la
même politique avec la même avec la même
vision des choses c'est à dire
l'amérique d'abord
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change l'équilibré
stratégique pour le moyen-orient après
50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette région
complexe preuve était le seul à pouvoir
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
grâce à ses relations différentes avec
tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment jma va traiter un sujet s'il
relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
la france est elle à la hauteur des
enjeux climatiques
on reprend ce débat avec rémy prud'homme
qui pensent que la france en fait plutôt
trop il est économiste et ex directeur
adjoint de la direction de
l'environnement la cdc l'auteur de sans
caillou dans la chaussure de monsieur
macron qui vient juste de paraître à
l'artilleur est du côté de ceux qui
pensent que la france n'en fait pas
assez il ya dominique bourg
il est philosophe ancien président du
conseil scientifique de la fondation
nicolas hulot
il est l'auteur de retour sur terre sans
proposition qui est paru aux presses
universitaires de france
la parole est à vous dominique bourg sur
le nucléaire
l'assuré clair je voulais déjà
premièrement il faut pas dire que le
nucléaire c'est une énergie décarbonée
n'y a pas d'énergie aujourd'hui
malheureusement qu'ils soient totalement
décalé c'est une énergie faiblement
carbonée mais quand vous regardez si
vous voulez la masse de béton d'acier
que vous avez dans une centrale ensuite
après la fabrication du cardio alors
maintenant ça c'est beaucoup moins
énergivore que ça ne l'était il ya
quelques décennies mais c'est donc
l'énergie effectivement faiblement
carbonée
mais alors elle présente bien d'autres
des avantages qu'ils voulaient et
notamment en termes de coûts franchement
ce qui si vous souhaitez la réaction du
directeur financier d'edf
face à une crise qui disait justement il
est qu'il est allé missionné tellement
il était inquiet si vous voulez et quand
on veut faire un peu plus de sécurité
ainsi quels cas de la génération de 2,2
le père de la génération iii plus avec
le père on n'a jamais réussi à
construire un sauf en chine et on sait
pas vraiment d'ailleurs s'il est
totalement le p r donc voilà ça c'est
une énergie qui est problématique les
déchets c'est pour le ticket question
sécurité ces problématiques auxquelles
est aussi ont même dansé blement
faiblement carbonée ensuite après si
franchement on en faisait une ressource
mondiale avec la avec l'uranium 235 en
aurez assez vite des a sévi des
problèmes seraient moins vrai pour le
thorium mais c'est sait pour le moment
c'est pas du tout quelque chose
l'industrialisation voilà on est un peu
dans une donne énergétique hendon
complexe c'est pas simple il faut
essayer d'éviter l'idéologie
de toute façon on fait conférer un coût
zéro et a en fait on doit faire une
espèce de pondération des risques si
vous voulez entre le risque climatique
et moi j'aime pas parler de risques
climatiques seul si je voulais je
voulais rappeler tout à l'heure le
climat s'est simplement les conditions
d'épanouissement du vivant or on est si
vous voulez dans une situation
d'effondrement du vivant sur terre ce
que l'on peut dire à venir et que bien
sûr le climat va encore sur aggravée
donc on est dans ces conditions là
l'enjeu c'est en fait la viabilité pour
l'espèce humaine et pour les autres
espèces de la terre dans les décennies
qui étaient les siècles qui viennent
mais déjà malheureusement dans les
décennies qui viennent
voilà il faut faire la pesée des risques
et qu'est-ce qu'on veut me prud'homme
oui sur le nucléaire d'abord il ya un
point sur lequel il faut revenir c'est
celui de l'augmentation éventuelle de la
demande d'électricité en europe
en europe la demande d'électricité
n'augmente plus du tout depuis une bonne
dizaine d'années alors elle augmente
évidemment extrêmement rapidement en
chine et en inde mais pas à pas en
europe pas en france en tout cas alors
augmentera tel dans les années à venir
il ya des gens qui le pense qu'il ya des
gens qu'ils disent de toute façon il
faut se méfier de ces chiffres là parce
que là le le co2 que la france rejette
celui que dans les enjeux climatiques on
voudrait réduire
il a pour contrepartie le co2 que l'on
importe quand on achète des des chemises
chinoise parce que elles ont été
produites en chine avec de l'électricité
extrêmement carbonées donc les éoliennes
c'est la faille prendre ce point en
compte
pardon et les éoliennes c'est la lie les
éoliennes les éoliennes c'est pareil -
parce que les bonnes parties des des
turbines sont fabriqués en allemagne et
aux dames
mais les panneaux solaires en effet sauf
à briquet en chine
donc ça c'est un point qu'il faut garder
en tête
dire que la construction d'une centrale
nucléaire consomment beaucoup de avec le
béton consomment beaucoup 2e g de co2
c'est relativement à l'éolien inexactes
produire la même quantité d'électricité
avec de l'éolien
chaque éolienne ses 1500 tonnes de béton
euh c'est pas très très bon pour la vie
des sols la perméabilité des sols c'est
même très mauvais et ça fait beaucoup
plus que le sait le beto que dont on a
besoin pour faire une centrale nucléaire
donc l'idée de fermer des centrales
nucléaires ou uniquement pour faire
plaisir aux écologistes quand il s'agit
d'une électricité qui est bon marché qui
ne rejette pas de co2 ou qui en
rejettent moins que à peu près n'importe
quel autre source d'électricité qui est
qui n'a pas recours aux importations
parce que la quantité d'uranium que l'on
que l'on importe c'est dérisoire par
rapport aux coûts alors que en matière
de e 2 2 solaire et d'éolien on importe
l'essentiel de l'étranger que en matière
de technologie la france était l'un des
pays du monde peut-être même le pays du
monde qui maîtrisaient le mieux la
technologie nucléaire
c'est véritablement cassé
l'industrie française le respect de la
nature et même le co2 c'est moi je suis
très frappé de voir que cette politique
qui a consisté à être anti nucléaires
qui a reposé sur des mensonges
parce que les antinucléaires ont réussi
à faire croire aux français que le
nucléaire rejeter beaucoup de co2 on a
des enquêtes qui montre que 85 % des
français sont persuadés que le nucléaire
rejette beaucoup de co2 d'où ça vient ça
vient de ce que les gouvernements et
surtout les écologistes ont répété ce
mensonge si souvent qu'ils ont réussi à
convaincre les français de ce qui est
une inexactitude évidente que même
monsieur bourg reconnaîtra comme tel
mais pour revenir au nucléaire il ya un
point qui est très frappant c'est que la
france est en train de perdre pied
complètement les pays qui actuellement
produisent du nuc les centrales
nucléaires c'est la chine
c'est la russie qui est le premier
exportateur de nucléaire dans le monde
c'est la corée ça n'est plus la france
et il ya là quelque chose qui est
particulièrement triste parce que c'est
l'un des fleurons de la science et de la
technologie française qui est étranglé
par les amis de monsieur hulot par
rapport justement à notre industrie
on entend de plus en plus y compris les
patrons des grandes firmes automobiles
françaises nous dire que l'avenir ce
sont les véhicules électriques et qui
vont remplacer les véhicules tels que
nous les connaissons aujourd'hui qui
consomment du pétrole est ce que ça vous
semble véritablement être l'avenir
dominique bourreau et lé véhicule
électrique
oui justement c'est une manière de
revenir s'ils voulaient ce qui vient
d'être dit très très très rapidement
c'est vrai que ces dernières années dans
les pays anciennement industriels
la consommation d'électricité montez pas
ou très peu ça va devenir de moins en
moins vrai si vous regardez par exemple
le secteur du numérique c'est déjà
aujourd'hui 4 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mondiales avec une
croissance de 9% évidemment la 5g va pas
arranger va pas arranger la chose et par
certains côtés s'ils voudront va
substituer parce que ça ça a l'air
d'être plus propre on va substituer à
certaines sources d'énergie non pas une
source l'électricité qui est un vecteur
faut la produire de l'énergie pour la
produire et donc ça ça va faire que la
tendance serait plutôt à l'avenir
normalement serait plutôt à
l'augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie dans nos pays parce que on va
shift est effectivement vous parlez de
voitures électriques alors soyons clairs
mais dans un pays comme la france où
fait nucléaire c'est tout à fait dupe de
rien le contraire d'électricité
faiblement carbonées et bien même en
france quand vous achetez une zoé
il faut vous ayez parc rue où je passe
un peu plus mais au moins cent mille
kilomètres avant d'économiser 1 où le
moindre gramme de carbone et ce qui a
été dit par monsieur prix va peut-être
un peu fort les grosses éoliennes 4
mégawatts c'est à peu près oui un socle
de 1000 tonnes de béton mais pas qu'un
sens mais bombay de douvres et la raison
en termes de ratio entre énergie
produite et quantité de matières
mobiliser c'est pas génial quand même
mais ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
l'éolien c'est une technique est devenu
mature aujourd'hui
en revanche les panneaux solaires là au
contraire quand on parle de retour sur
investissement énergétique comme je lis
tout à l'heure c'est déjà tout à fait
correct on s'attend à une belle
augmentation par palier dans disons les
deux trois décennies qui qui viennent
parce que là avec le solaire on n'est
pas du tout dans une technologie qui est
qui est mature donc oui de façon
générale pour résumer si vous voulez le
nucléaire au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
une électricité qui est peu carbonée
mais qui présente d'autres difficultés
et quand on part du coût du nucléaire
franchement c'est un peu une galéjade
hessel ça l'a été depuis le début c'est
à dire quand en fait il suffit que vous
ayez un accident france qui est pas
malheureusement improbable
il suffit que vous ayez un accident en
france me garder
le coup de fourchette fukushima au japon
bah ça vous plombe complètement votre
prix de l'électricité sans parler des de
l'incidence humaines et en terme de
sécurité et d'environnement manière
générale pour les dessiner qui vont se
dire le moore et df avait provisionné
mais reste plus grand-chose simulé sur
la désinstallation des centrales
on n'y a qu'une seule centrale qu on a
démonté au monde qu'elle est aux états
unis c'est un coup femme ne s que la
france et df serons en mesure de le
faire je vous le demande donc imaginer
les problèmes que ça représente
la question du stockage des déchets on a
toujours pas de solution qui soit qu'ils
soient vraiment fiable alors
effectivement vous avez raison le la
russie est un acteur majeur en termes de
production nucléaire et franchement
c'est quand même pas un acteur majeur en
termes de souci de la santé de ses
habitants pas que demander à nabeul à
l'avenir il va vous le dire la chute
dans le genre c'est pas beaucoup eu donc
effectivement les pays où continuent à
développer le nucléaire
à l'exception dans le texte ce sont
plutôt des pays qui sont pas très
soucieux de la santé de la santé et de
l'art assortissant et et non plus de la
santé de la planète l'humanité en
général aux mêmes questions rémy
prud'homme à ce que les véhicules
électriques ne sait l'avenir et j'ai
envie de demander est ce que le rail est
un secteur d'avenir parce qu'en général
on a tendance à l'opposé par rapport au
transport routier gros émetteur de co2
qu'il faut absolument combattre
alors on dit tout de suite le rail alors
le rail et il a secteur d'avenir et les
véhicules électriques sont ils un
secteur d'avenir à vos à vos yeux la
réponse est non deux fois à mon avis
s'agissant des voitures électriques
c'est absurde de dire qu'elles sont
propres qu'elle ne rejette pas de co2 du
tout le calcul a été fait il est
difficile à faire parce qu'il dépend
totalement de l'endroit où la voiture
roule de l'électricité qu'elle achète et
son caractère plus ou moins carboné
d'une part et de l'endroit où les
batteries ont été fabriqués les
rencontres pratique en chine
et quand on fait de tout le compte les
voitures électriques dans la plupart des
pays du monde rejette beaucoup plus de
co2 que une voiture qui fonctionne avec
du vilain diesel alors c'est pas
forcément le cas en france la france qui
est l'un des pays du monde où
l'électricité est la moins carbonée
c'est une question sur laquelle il faut
revenir quand on se pose la question de
savoir si la france est à la hauteur
dans ce domaine dans le cas de la france
une voiture électrique qui roulent en
france si les batteries étaient
fabriqués en france ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas
cette voiture la rejetterait au cours de
toute son existence au cours de de sa
vie elle rejetterait un peu moins de co2
que une voiture qui roule à l'essence ou
au diesel
mais dès que l'on quitte la france si on
prend le cas de l'allemagne par exemple
qui a une électricité qui est six fois
ou sept fois plus carbonées que la
france ça n'est plus vrai et s'agissant
de la chine qui est le pays au monde où
il y a le plus de voiture électrique la
leaf sa voiture électrique la rejettent
plus de co2 dans l'atmosphère du globe
que si elle était muet avec du pétrole
ou de dut du diesel
donc il faut être très prudent quand on
voit l'avenir du véhicule dans
l'électricité qui est d'état
d'industriels qui pour la raison que les
voitures électriques sont subventionnés
d'une façon indécente parce que
pratiquement dans tous les pays on n'est
pas loin de dix mille euros par voiture
pour des voitures qui sont
essentiellement des voitures des
deuxième voiture et qui sont utilisés
presque uniquement par des riches
actuellement on les subventionne à
hauteur de 10000 euros
la voiture ce qui est quand même très
choquant d'un point de vue d'un point de
vue éthique
ça c'est pour la voiture électrique
s'agissant de cette idée qui consiste à
dire on va se transporter en voiture ou
en transports en commun en chemin de fer
ou en métro c'est une idée qui traîne
depuis quarante ans et qui ne se produit
pas du tout là là parmi les le projet de
loi qui est va être discutée qui est
discutée aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres vous allez trouver une fois de
plus ça sera là la 10e
l'idée qu'il faut doubler le fret
ferroviaire
cette idée est complètement absurde le
fret ferroviaire coûtent des sommes
absolument extravagantes absolument
extravagantes
il recule partout en dépit des
subventions et malgré p les les taxes
extraordinairement élevés qui pèsent sur
les voitures
alors on peut toujours dépenser de
l'argent à fonds perdus je sais que
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
actuellement sur une échelle inédite
mais il y a tout de même un moment où
l'argent que l'on dépense dans des des
tunnels absurdes comme celui de lyon
turin et qui pour de secours pour des
trains qui sont comme qui sont vos hôtes
aux trois quarts vide la moitié du temps
parle d des trains régionaux
tout ça avec des des dizaines de
milliards on sait que le chemin de fer
nous coûtent 15 milliards par an
actuellement
et c'est pas à cause du salaire les deux
ouvriers de la sncf comme on a voulu
nous le faire croire et c'est l'idée que
c'est en réduisant un peu les plus
petits avantages de ces travailleurs que
l'on va éliminer se coupent mance annuel
de dudu trains en france qu' on va
arriver à quelque chose
donc l'idée c'est ça plaît beaucoup de
dire on va mettre les voitures sur des
trains on va le train il est très lent
quand non pas quand ils roulent mais
quand quelqu'un veut transporter un lot
de produits d'une dune d'une usine à un
autre endroit
il faut d'abord l'emmener en camion
jusqu'à une gare il faut attendre très
longtemps qu'il ya un train qui veuille
bien partir ce train ne va pas
directement à l'endroit où on veut aller
faut que ça soit changée finalement la
vitesse de du départ à l'arrivée elle
est de 15 kilomètres à l'heure et ça ne
convient pas du tout au monde moderne
qui veut que les marchandises soient
déplacés très très rapidement donc il ya
beaucoup de deux mythes alors c'est très
sympathique le train moi j'aime beaucoup
voyagé en train c'est plus agréable que
de voyager en voiture mais c'est c'est
ça se fait à un coût qui est tel que il
il est totalement déraisonnable
d'imaginer que on va obtenir des
résultats importants d'ailleurs la part
du du chemin de fer est maintenant
devenu tellement faible notamment en
matière de de marchandises ont dit 10%
mais c'est 10 % quand on le mesure en
tonnes kilomètres et la tonne kilomètre
est une façon très archaïque d'évaluer
la l'activité d'un secteur industriel
personne n'aurait l'idée de 2,2 comparé
la chimie fine c'est à dire les les
vaccins ou les parfums avec la chimie
lourde qui est le les engrais azotés ou
l'acide chlorhydrique personne n'aurait
cette idée absurde de mesurer sa entonne
on le mesure en argent on le mesure ce
que les gens payent pour voir leurs
produits transportés et le fret
ferroviaire il fait à peu près 2% en
comptant large du total du fret en
france donc fondé des espoirs sur le
transfert de la route vers le rail
c'est carré c'est une chimère que l'on
que l'on caresse depuis vingt ans il y
avait des gens revue dix fois des plans
qui allaient multiplier par deux les
mêmes vues il ya même eu un ministre
comme il se plaît un ministre est
sympathique la communiste du de nîmes
qui voulaient multi qui a écrit ça a été
décidé ça a été voté au parlement que
l'on allait multiplier par trois la part
du fret
on pourrait peut-être attaquer en
justice le fait que cette promesse
intenable n'a pas été réalisé en dix ans
l'état n'a pas fait ce qu'il allait dire
ce qu'il a dit qu'il allait faire mal
mais personne ne veut se couvrir de
ridicule à ce point là alors dominique
bourg résumé ce que ce que dit rémi
prud'hom cinq ans go toutes ces
décisions sait rien pour le climat est
beaucoup contre les pauvres visiblement
alors est ce que notre ami et mais assez
cocasse non il ya qu'à un domaine avec
lequel je suis d'accord avec ce qu'il
vient de dire monsieur prudhomme c'est
sur le lyon turin
mais justement il est en réduction est
lui-même parce que le lyon turin c'est
exactement son raisonnement c'est
simplement gagner quelques minutes sur
un trajet alors non ce qui est dit sur
le train tout à fait fondée ici à des
conditions dans lesquelles effectivement
il est peut-être pas intéressant mais
moi même je n'ai pas de voiture
quand je vais à paris vous imaginez bien
que si je prends une voiture je vis met
un temps infini
je ne serais pas où la gare et tout cela
en trimant aucun intérêt je suis désolé
je prends le train et on suisse comme au
bout d puisque je suis franco suisse
quand vous vous déplacez ya pratiquement
pas de camions sur les routes
tout simplement parce que effectivement
dans ce pays il a bien organisé
vous avez un ferroutage très important
donc il suffit simplement vous passer la
frontière et vous allez voir que ce que
vous raconte monsieur prudhomme est
complètement faux en revanche ce que je
peux vous dire là sur la voiture les
tricks radio moins caricatural je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure
avec les techniques d'aujourd'hui si
vous prenez une zoé en france et au
moins 108 km si vous l'avez en allemagne
ça va être 125 130 135 pour vous
commencez à économiser un grave
donc en fait non si on veut vraiment
prendre le problème au sérieux et on
sera obligé le pronom sérieux demandé
aux habitants de la vésubie de la roya
on va finir par le prendre au sérieux on
va le prendre assez rapidement le
sérieux et ça commence bah oui mais il
ya des choses qui deviennent impossibles
donc c'est sûr que d'imaginer qu'on va
avoir tous nos transports en électrique
et qu'on aura la même quand il
exactement la même mobilité qu'avant ça
effectivement c'est sans doute une
illusion en tout cas là on va avoir une
mobilité plus collective et et le
collectif en question il peut s'adapter
en tout cas pour les grands trajets là
vous avez des flux très importants
le train reste effectivement quelque
chose de très important pour les
marchandises c'est effectivement plus
compliqué puisque de toute façon vous
aurez un camion pour aller jusqu'à la
gare et un camion ensuite pour pour pour
desservir mais en tout cas sur la
mobilité individuelle c'est clair que le
tout voiture qu'on a connus d'une façon
ils donnent des congestions physique
c'est quelque chose qui est absurde
on va pas pouvoir de maintenir ça c'est
une certitude
l'illusion serait d'imaginer qu'on va
tous reportés sur l'électrique ça c'est
une autre illusion au site
c'est clair la seule chose qui vous
reste c'est le mobilité différentes en
jour sur l'intermodalité et puis
évidemment une mobilité qui sera plus
souvent collectifs qu'elle ne l'était
avant
il n'y a pas tellement choix là dessus
alors dernière dernière question dernier
mot il nous reste trois minutes on a
choisi de tout arrêter contre le devine
donc de réduire notre bible donc réduire
notre richesse
faut-il faire exactement la même chose
contre le réchauffement
dominique bourra l'air de dire oui faut
pas se faire d'illusions nous dit il il
y aura des choses en moi faut l'accepter
ça a pas l'air d'être votre cas rémy
prud'homme alors réponse court terme
puisqu'il nous reste que deux minutes va
laisser monsieur prudhomme répondre oui
mais c'est effectivement l'idée qu'il y
a
chez les écologistes c'est de vivre
moins bien c'est d'avoir moins de
mobilité
ses deux passes
déplacer ça provient aussi de ce que ce
sont des gens qui habitent le marais où
qu'ils habitent lausanne et qui n'ont
pas besoin de voiture mais allez donc
tenir ce ce raisonnement qu'on va se
passer de voiture dans la creuse et vous
verrez comment vous serez reçus le
revenu des gens de la creuse
il est quatre ou cinq fois plus bas que
le revenu de monsieur bourré même que le
mien mais moi je pense pas uniquement
moi comme j'ai une voiture mais je
n'utilise pratiquement pas moi je peux
très bien me passer de voiture mais les
les pauvres gens qui habitent dans
l'ensemble de la france soit
périphériques soient rurales
c'est absurde de leur demander de se
passer de voiture c'est les condamner à
pour la jeune stéphanoise est long et
ils l'ont bien ils l'ont bien expliqué
de l'ordre de réclusion de l'actrice de
ville et jaune à la même question
sociale dans les accords si vous
permettez quand même ce qui est vraiment
très important justement on est encore
en train de vivre la copie d des choses
sont en train de s'apercevoir que là il
pensait qu'il allait en sortir c'est son
look beaucoup plus compliqué que ça on a
un virus qui s'est installé il y aura
des mutations faudra remettre au jour
les vaccins simplement quand vous
écoutez les économistes ils vous disent
lakovic et une externalité c'est un
accident extérieur à l'économie ça c'est
une région suis totalement désole la
cuve vide
c'est la conséquence de notre modèle
économique est là qu vite je vous assure
que par rapport au climat et à d'autres
problèmes c'est franchement pas grand
chose donc soit on continue à sillonner
soit on répète les erreurs du passé
soient effectivement des seuils de
réfléchir ensemble à ce qu'il faut faire
alors c'est sûr si on propose aux gens
du jour au lendemain dans la creuse
n'est pas avoir de voiture
c'est sûr que ça va pas marcher mais
rassurez vous c'est parce qu'on leur
propose non plus je remercie tous les
deux d'avoir participé à cette émission
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis et
je vous donne rendez-vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]